did you enjoy if you look back do you
think you really loved working on
Smallville was it something that you go
you know this was
a many years of my life that I I spent
on this show and playing this character
it's probably one of the most well-known
characters you played right yeah I loved
it I loved it you loved it and then you
know then then seven I was gone and then
nine and 10 yeah they made him just a
villain the the writers were they didn't
I was so I was so excited that when they
said an alternate universe that they
were going to come up with some great
stuff but they just played out andout
stereotypical villains so you didn't
like that no did you tell them